Luna thank you so much for being here
with me oh thank you for having me of
course so let's start by talking about
what exactly does your company do so at
Genesis bio we take organic waste all
kinds of forms food waste or Industrial
Waste and we convert that into
compostable Plastics very cool how did
you get the idea for this so back during
my master's program in University of
Toronto I had a chance to visit a biog
gas facility where they convert food
waste into biog gas and then very Qui
quickly I realized that throughout the
entire process there's these really
great carbons you can get from food
waste that can also be fed to much more
efficient bacteria to make higher value
products
[Music]
instead a lot of companies today and
especially a lot of startups are looking
at ESG and looking at you know the
climate crisis and doing things I think
to kind of just like tick a box and say
okay you know we're helping the
environment is there a personal mission
that you're motivated by for me
personally I actually grew up in China
and one of the most polluted cities so
growing up I saw a bunch of pollution
smog everywhere so I thought we need to
be able to do something to really help
alleviate that and how how are you
working to do that now well so with our
technology we basically take organic
waste feed stocks that would otherwise
go into landfills in the landfills they
actually release roughly 7% of
greenhouse gas emissions as they degrade
right and so by essentially diverting
that stream away from landfills and
converting that into compostable
Plastics we can essentially offset a
huge amount of carbon emissions
who are your customers tell me a little
bit about who you're making this for
absolutely so traditionally our
customers has been B2B customers so
large cpg Brands like Noel NIS canun
lver but this year we're actually
planning to launch our own products
directly to Consumers so it'll be really
exciting to see that what type of
products in the food and beverage space
as well as in the Cosmetic space with
phas I want to get a sense of the the
scale of your company can you talk to me
a bit about either customers or sales or
anything like that that'll help me
understand absolutely so this year we
have roughly around $5 million in
revenues plus around $10 million in
purchase orders and additional deals
that we have signed in terms of the
impact that we can have we really do
think that next year is going to be a
big year for us because Beyond just the
B2B sales we will be launching those
products direct to Consumers and that's
where we do believe that we can do a lot
more better job in terms of marketing it
and bringing about a new type of plastic
to the world
so talk to me about your fundraising
Journey how'd you get to where you are
today I think we're really lucky to have
a lot of great investors backing us so
for example series a we raised last year
with coal Ventures leading the round and
then earlier this year we had Amazon
pledge fund co-lead our series a
extension and we're also backed by y
combinator so just really really great
to be connected with all these amazing
people what's your total funding right
now we have raised roughly $7 million to
date and then we also have roughly $15
million of grant funding I'm Luna from
Genesis bioindustries so what's it like
to be a such a young founder and be a a
woman in a very M dominated science
heavy space I'd say I think it's
actually a privilege to be honest I
think because of who we are like we
actually really stand out in the
industry and a lot of times maybe it's a
negative but we like to see the positive
side of things and really use it to our
advantage so for example
when our company was first founded back
in 2018 we actually won some great women
founder Focus pitch competitions and you
know that was sort of an exclusive
access only we had access to so just
really being able to capitalize on that
I
think if you could go back in time and
tell yourself one piece of advice the
day before you launched your company
what would it be I think if I were to go
back in time the biggest advice I give
to myself is learn how to fail fast
learn how to to basically experiment on
ideas and figure out what the most
riskiest element is to that drisk it
first and if it doesn't work then move
on and basically adjust
[Music]
course